[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTHONY PASSEMARD: Hey,
welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Anthony Passemard,
the head of product
for our Cloud IoT offering.
And today, we're going to be
talking about IoT security
and how to make your
solutions secure.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Google Earth
on standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
So making IoT solutions secure.
Security is top of
mind for everybody.
It's mostly driven because of
all the recent attacks that's
been in the news
around IoT security.
Think about Mirai.
Mirai was taking over
some cameras in the wild
and using them to do distributed
denial of service attacks.
That was 2.5 million
devices affected
by this kind of attack.
More recently, things
like Meltdown and Spectre
literally touched
about every computer
out there, including
IoT devices.
That was a big one that
needed to be solved.
So all those security
issues, and even
a more recent one with Z-Wave,
are putting a lot of pressure
into IT professionals and
people working on IoT to really
make those solutions secure.
So today, we're going to talk
about how to make that secure.
There's more and more
devices out there.
A lot of people
throw big numbers.
What I like to look at
is the current number
of devices and the growth,
so about 8.4 billion devices
connected today.
It's growing about 30% a year.
What that tells me
is the attack surface
is actually growing rapidly.
It's not so much the
number of devices,
just every new device out
there is a new opportunity
for an attacker to take
over and cause some damage.
So that's what's worrisome
about the growth.
And it can come from everywhere.
We've seen, for example,
there was a hack
in a casino in the US,
where the casino got hacked
through a fish tank thermostat.
So some attacker got
into that thermostat that
was in the casino and,
through that thermostatic,
got access to the network and
got access to a bunch of data
from the players in the casino.
That was a pretty big deal.
They actually didn't
discover that attack
for a little bit of time.
And we're wondering why
this thermostat was sending
so much data out to the cloud.
Well, now they know what.
It was a little
bit of a big deal.
But that shows
you the importance
of securing the IoT devices,
not only the network itself.
71% of the attacks
go undetected.
So that's a big number.
We need to do better here.
And it's really more than money.
It's also the reputation.
You've probably heard about
the Equifax breach, where
all those social security
numbers, information
about users, were pulled
out of their system.
Really worrisome, to be honest.
Their stock price fell
30% right the same day--
I mean, the day after
the attack was unveiled.
And that's pretty rough.
You're talking
millions of dollars
lost because of that attack.
So it's not just money.
It's also your reputation.
I don't know if I would
trust Equifax anymore.
I don't know.
Maybe.
But you've got to
really consider
the cost of being
hacked as a device
and being in the news
and people talking
about your devices being hacked.
That's sometimes more
important than just the money.
So security cannot
be an afterthought.
It has to be built
in your system.
It has to start from
the ground up as you're
building your solution.
And also, we'll
look at some ways
to retrofit those solutions.
But it cannot be
an afterthought.
And this is the subject here.
The problem is it's
really complicated.
You talk about mechanical
designs and PCB designs.
We're talking about
the supply chain
and securing the
supply chain, talking
about the firmware development,
the security of the firmware,
the network connectivity,
your Cloud back
end, your mobile and web
apps, even the processing
and analytics, the support
over time-- something
that people overlook often.
They'll secure a device,
but what happens two years
from now, five years from now?
How do you keep
that device secure?
And the overall cost and ROI and
the business model associated,
you have to think
about all of this
as you're building a solution.
And security has to come in
all of those items, as well.
So we're going to look
at four different areas
of your solution, starting
from hardware and connectivity,
how to secure that; the
IoT platform, the device
management, the ETL,
ingestion, how to secure that;
the big data, ML, and AI;
and then the mobile, web,
and back end that cuts
across those three buckets.
We'll focus more on the hardware
and connectivity on the IoT
platform today.
We'll assume that the security
of mobile apps, web apps,
and big data and ML,
that's kind of taken
care of, because the subject
is more around the IoT
side of things.
So first thing is to choose
a platform that is secure.
And you can cover yourself, your
trust, but you have to verify.
This is why, for example,
the Google Cloud Platform
has ISO certification,
HIPAA compliance, FedRAMP,
a lot of the certification
that are verified
by third-party vendors to say,
yes, Google Cloud is secure.
You can trust them.
Put your data in there.
But also, we are working
with other institutions,
like the FDIC or some of
the other logos in there,
to really stay ahead and look
at the security holistically
and really try to find those
problems before they occur.
So that's a very
important effort
that Google is undertaking,
making the Google Cloud
Platform extremely
secure for your solution.
We really built that solution
at Google from the ground up.
We're thinking security at the
hardware level, any software,
the storage, the identity,
looking at the network
and operations of that network.
We're really thinking security
at every layer of that cake
here to make sure that we offer
those secure solutions for you
and you can trust that
cloud infrastructure
for your application, your
analytics, your ML and AI.
You can trust those to
build your IoT solution.
So to illustrate how you can
secure your IoT solution,
we really wanted to go through
a little bit of a story time
and tell the story of a company.
And you can pick any name.
I'll take Acme, for example.
And take a company that wants
to build an IoT device today.
What do they have to look at?
And what do they go through
in their journey to a solution
and to make that secure?
So they have to look at
encryption, obviously,
of data, authentication
of devices and users,
at the manufacturing
security, at the boot,
and at the key
rotation over time.
So those are five
elements that are really
important to look at as they're
building their solution.
So we're going to go
through each of them
and see how to make that secure.
So the first thing
is data encryption.
So data encryption, here, we're
talking about data encryption
in transit.
TLS is what most
people should be using.
It's a very standard protocol.
It's used to connect
to your bank,
if you're familiar with that.
I mean, TLS is very well known.
It's very well deployed.
It's been battle tested.
This is something
that you should always
have between your device and
the Cloud Platform, the Google
Cloud Platform.
You should be using TLS for
data encryption in transit.
That's very important,
and that's a given.
That's the first thing.
So they say, OK, we'll
use TLS to communicate
between our device and
the Google Cloud Platform.
Great.
Now, how do you authenticate?
We have encryption.
We need to authenticate
those devices.
There's two ways to authenticate
devices, if you wish.
There's kind of a
certificate-based
authentication and a
password-based authentication.
Do not use password
based for devices.
Passwords are for human.
Password is an element that
somebody has in their head,
and the head is
the secure storage.
You're not supposed to
write it down in a Post-it
and put it on your keyboard.
That's not how you do it.
You keep it in your head.
And then because I know the
password, I can authenticate.
So I'm the secure element here.
The problem with a password
is if somebody else
knows your password,
that other person is you.
There's no validation that you
are the person you say you are.
You're just showing a
password, and it says, I am me.
And that's why the secure
storage in your head
is very important is to
prove that it is you.
That's the main issue
with a password.
A password is you.
With a certificate, there's
a certificate authority
that validates that
what you're presenting
as an identity is actually you.
So that authority will say,
yes, yes, that public key,
that certificate, great.
That's device ABC,
and that's great.
So you should always use
certificate for devices,
because you don't have the
head as a secure storage,
as a human does.
So this is very important.
And also, that third-party
validation of the identity
is very important.
So use certificate for devices.
Fine.
So Acme says, OK, we'll
use TLS for encryption.
We'll use certificate
for identity.
But then I have certificates.
So I have public keys
and private keys.
How do I give those
keys to my manufacturer?
How do I put those
keys on my device?
And that's actually
a pretty big problem.
There are several
ways you can do that.
You can create a file
with all the keys
and send that file
to your manufacturer.
That's one way to do it.
You have to trust your
manufacturer at this point,
because the manufacturer
sees your keys,
and they can actually
copy those keys
if they're malicious a bit.
It does happen fairly
often that the manufacturer
will generate all your devices,
send your devices, fine.
And then all of a sudden, you
see maybe 10% of those devices
are rogue devices, are fake
devices, but using valid keys.
They're copies of existing keys,
because they were in a file,
and they've been copied.
So that's a little
bit of an issue.
So that's not really
a good way to do it.
The other way is to
say, hey, manufacturer,
you're going to do an
API call every time
you're going to flash that
firmware and my identities.
You're going to do an
API call to a back end
to get the keys right on time.
The manufacturers hate
that, because it slows down
the manufacturing process.
So imagine that you have
called to get the key.
That's a round trip.
They get to download that key.
They have to flash it.
And then they go
to the next device.
That's fairly slow.
And what happens sometimes
is that call doesn't work.
That call's too slow.
It's slowing down the
manufacturing process,
which adds cost to you.
So when they do that,
they will actually
charge you way more than just a
standard manufacturing process
that goes really fast.
That's costing a lot of
money, and they usually
don't like that.
Actually, a lot of
manufacturers don't even
have their manufacturing line
connected to the internet.
They don't even
allow you to do this.
So you revert to
giving them a file
with the copies of the keys.
So that's not great.
So we need to find
a solution for that.
TLS mutual authentication.
So this is the authentication.
We say what we're going to use.
We're going to use certificates.
Great.
So the certificate can be used
to authenticate the cloud,
like you would authenticate
with your bank.
When you do that, you
know it's the bank,
but the bank doesn't
know it's you until you
put username, password.
It's the same for device.
They can authenticate the cloud.
The cloud needs to
authenticate the device,
so it's a mutual
authentication both ways.
And you can use TLS
mutual auth to do that.
There's good and bad for it.
It's not all good.
So we'll look at that.
And finally, secure boot.
We want to make sure
that what the device is
running when it boots is
what's supposed to be running.
The first thing that a hacker
will do when they get onto
a device, they'll modify the
firmware so the device cannot
do what it's
supposed to be doing.
Mirai was doing that.
Mirai would get on
the device, shut
off everything, every
other connection,
and reconfigure itself.
So nobody else could come in.
Actually, it would shut
down any other Mirai
attack, which was pretty good.
But it would shut down
any access to the device.
Then it would
reconfigure the device
to do what it wanted it to do.
So make sure that
when the device boots,
there is a validation
of the firmware that
says, yes, yes, it is right.
It is the right firmware.
And it's supposed to
boot the right way,
and it's doing the right thing.
So I let the device boot.
So that's secure boot.
And that's really important
to implement in your device.
And the key rotation is
something that is actually
forgotten quite often.
You need to think
more than a year away.
No, think four years,
five, 10 years, 15 years.
In manufacturing, we see
15, 20 years sometimes.
Keys will rotate, will
have to be rotated.
Sometimes, they're corrupted.
There's been a hack in your
back end system, in your CA.
The keys have been exposed.
You have to rotate them.
Maybe the CA has to be
rotated every few years.
And that's very important.
That's hard to do.
So you have to really consider
throughout your design
that the keys are ephemeral
and will have to be changed.
So that's something very
important to consider
when you build your device.
Think that your keys are
not going to be permanent
and will have to be rotated.
How does your
software and firmware
manage that to make sure that
that's feasible over time?
That's a very important point
that's oftentimes overlooked.
So if you look at
all the challenges--
so you need certificates
and a certificate authority.
And there's complexity
coming with that.
The manufacturing cost
and risk associated
with transferring the keys
to your manufacturer, that's
a problem.
TLS and TLS mutual auth is
actually a little bit loaded
and hard to maintain.
So we'll see how
we can solve this.
Keys are extremely difficult
to store securely in firmware.
If it's firmware or software,
somebody can have access to it.
Somebody can reverse engineer
the code and decompile
and can get access
to those keys.
It's extremely hard to
secure any key in a firmware.
You have to do
secure boot, and you
have to have key
rotation management.
So those are six points that
are really big challenges.
And at this point,
you're probably thinking,
man, this is a problem.
How am I going to
secure my IoT devices?
This is too complicated.
Well, let's see how
we can help with that.
So let's talk a bit
about Google Cloud IoT.
The Google Cloud IoT Platform
is a set of services.
One of the most recent
is called Cloud IoT Core.
It's the big one
on the left here.
Cloud IoT Core has two
components-- a device manager,
where you'll declare your
devices, your attributes,
your registries, your access
controls, all of that,
and your keys.
You're going to store your
keys in there, the public keys.
And then you have a
data bridge or broker
for entry TTN and HTTP
to be able to communicate
bidirectionally with the
devices and between the devices
and the cloud.
All the data coming
into Cloud IoT Core
is passed on to Cloud Pub/Sub,
a globally available messaging
service.
From Pub/Sub, you can
tree your Cloud functions,
serverless functions,
and compute.
You can trigger data flows
that can do streaming analytics
over a certain period of time.
You can do transformation,
any kind of operation
at very high scale.
From there, you'll go into
storage in BigTable, BigQuery,
maybe Firestore, and trigger
Cloud ML training, if needed.
Those trainings could be used
by data flow or Cloud functions
to do inferences and then pass
back to the device eventually.
On the far right, Data Studio
and Datalab and analytics
allow you to visualize data.
Silly little time series.
See any information you
need about your data coming
from the devices.
That's our Cloud IoT platform.
It's a fully managed platform.
Cloud IoT Core is not
installed or deployed
or configured in terms of
shard size or anything.
It's a global service.
It will be accessible
anywhere in the world.
And it's scalable for you.
One device, million device,
doesn't really matter.
You just throw whatever
you have at it.
It will scale up and
down to your need.
So how do we secure all that?
Step one, use a secure element.
Use a crypto chip.
This is super important.
I cannot emphasize that enough.
You should use a crypto chip
in your device if you can.
The private keys from secure
chips are never exposed.
They are generated
inside the hardware.
Private key is generated
The public key is
generated and then exposed
so it can be distributed
to the back end.
This is super important.
We have a great partnership
with Microchip here on that.
You're talking subdollar.
It's really cheap to add.
And it saves you
a ton of trouble.
You can send that
crypto pre-configured
to your manufacturer
anywhere in the world,
even if you don't trust them.
Doesn't matter, because
they can't read anything
from that chip.
They'll just be able to
solder it to your PCB design,
and then you're good to go.
The identity has been
burned onto the device.
It's super secure.
There's really no
copying of keys possible.
There's no API calls that
the manufacturer has to do.
There's no constraint.
So the cost of manufacturing
is actually much, much cheaper.
And it oftentimes compensates
for the price of the chip.
That's super important.
I've seen customers
having to add $3 or $4
to do custom manufacturing
for each of the devices.
If you use this,
it's no more custom.
It's a single thing.
So you'd save $3 or $4 for a
chip that costs less than $1.
So that's a very
good value prop.
You should really
use a crypto chip.
The crypto chip can also
do secure boot, by the way.
So you can have the signature of
your firmware inside the crypto
chip.
When the device boots,
there's a hash that's
calculated of your firmware.
It's passed to the crypto.
The crypto can say yes or no.
And then the device
can boot or not.
So you're doing
secure provisioning
of keys, cheaper manufacturing
and more secure manufacturing.
You're doing secure
boot with this.
And also, we'll see,
you'll be able to do
key rotation with this.
So this is very important.
Even if you feel it's a little
bit expensive, please do it.
It will save you a ton of time.
It will save you a lot
of trouble down the line.
So use a secure [INAUDIBLE].
Second, the authentication.
I was talking about
mutual auth from TLS.
Mutual auth is
great, but there's
kind of a lot of downside to it.
So we recommend using a
JWT for authentication.
JWT is something that's used
by web services in general.
And then it's a standard.
It's a JSON web token.
The way it works-- and I have
a little schematic after that--
you establish a TLS session
with the Google front end
anywhere in the world.
As I said, Clout IoT
Core is a global service.
So anywhere in the world,
you'll hit that Google front end
with a TLS session.
You'll establish that TLS
session with Google front end.
Great.
No problem.
Then you're going to establish
your MQTT session over TLS.
To do that, you're going to
use username and password
from MQTT.
So you're not using the
mutual auth at this point.
You've established
your TLS session.
That's it.
But MQTT session has
username and password.
The CONNECT statement of the
MQTT has username and password.
Username is actually not used.
You can put anything
you want in there-- say,
"ignore" or "empty."
Doesn't matter.
The password is
actually not a password.
It's a JWT token,
a JSON web token,
that has a bunch of information
about the device, the device
ID, all of that, that is
signed by the private key,
so encrypted and signed by
the private key of the device.
With the little crypto
I showed you earlier,
that crypto is capable
of signing that JWT.
All the APIs are able to
do it with that crypto.
So it's very easy to do.
You sign that JWT
with your private key,
and you pass it
as your password.
That JWT will be
valid from whatever
you want to 24 hours, maximum.
So you will have to rotate
every 24 hours at minimum.
So that JWT is signed
and passed to IoT Core.
IoT Core will look at the device
ID, will find the public key,
and validate that the
signature from the private key
is actually valid.
And here you go.
You have your device
authentication.
So using that system, you
get mutual authentication
from both cloud and device
without using the TLS
mutual auth feature.
We support ECC and
RSA on IoT Core.
And that crypto that I showed
you can do both, as well.
Little schematic.
Bring it to life.
We have the provisioner.
The provisioner is a
person, is a company
who will buy the
chips from Microchip.
Microchip will
configure those keys
with your CA and
your certificates.
The private key is inside.
The public key is passed to you.
The provisioner
will run that script
to put all the public
keys in Device Manager.
All the public
keys are put there.
The devices are
not even created,
but all the public
keys are already there.
The crypto is passed on
the device, burned on it.
The device wakes up for the
first time, creates the JWT,
signs the JWT with a crypto,
connects to the broker.
The JWT is verified.
We already have the
public keys there.
We're all good to go.
It works.
So basically, doing that, you've
solved all of your problems.
So it's really nice.
So why not TLS mutual auth?
Why using JWT instead?
First thing is you achieve
mutual authentication
with JWT and TLS both.
So you achieve the same level
of authentication and security
with both solutions.
The benefit of the TLS
stack is much smaller.
All you need is to establish
the TLS session with the cloud.
That's all.
You don't need to
use the mutual auth
section of that stack, which
makes that stack much, much
smaller.
For example, we've
gone from 150 to 100k,
roughly, to 10k for
the entire stack.
So that's a big
difference, especially
for devices that oftentimes have
32k of memory or 64k of memory.
They can't put a
full TLS stack in it.
You have to use a
different solution.
This is what it brings you.
You can bring a
much smaller stack.
The speed is faster,
because you don't
have to do that whole
handshake in mutual auth
every time you establish
the TLS session.
All you have to do is one TLS--
boom.
Username, password.
You're done.
It's much faster, less
consuming in bandwidth.
There's no dependency on
the TLS stack you use.
You do not have to use a special
TLS stack that's optimized,
that has mutual auth
optimized and all of that.
You can use any TLS
stack you want--
open-source ones are very good--
because the only thing
you use is the TLS
session with your cloud.
So that's less dependence.
If you have to update the
TLS stack at some point--
from 1.2 to 1.3, for example--
your code is not dependent
on that TLS stack.
The fact that you
use a crypto is not
dependent on that TLS stack.
So the upgrade of the TLS stack
is much easier, much less risk,
much less testing to be done.
Supports crypto, because
your code does it,
not the TLS stack.
No dependency, again.
The ease of evolution
of the stack.
As I said, there's no
validation of your code.
Your code doesn't change.
You can change the TLS
stack all you want.
Your code's going
to be the same.
It's going to generate
the JWT, sign it, put it
as a password in
the MQTT CONNECT.
Very easy.
And then how do you support
multiple certificate here?
With Cloud IoT
Core, you can use up
to three certificates, so three
public keys per device, valley
public keys per device.
So what you'll do is you
have your public key.
You want to rotate it.
You'll create a
second public key.
You'll put it there.
You will re-authenticate.
You will also [INAUDIBLE]
with the first one.
Download all the information you
need for using the second key,
then rotate, because both
can be used at the same time.
And then you'll
invalidate the first one.
So you could do
those rotation up
to three keys at the same time.
And you could do those
rotations very easily.
It's much harder to do with the
mutual auth, because the TLS
stack has to know where
the certificates are,
et cetera, because
you are, again,
dependent on the TLS stack.
So by using the JWT token and
the signature with IoT core,
you're simplifying
your life a whole bunch
versus TLS mutual auth.
For bigger devices, there's
an added layer of security
that you can use.
For MCU class devices,
you'll have to use whatever--
Mongoose OS or Express
Logic or any of the--
Zephyr from the Unix foundation.
You should have
used some of those.
But for larger devices that
have CPU class processors,
you can use Android Things.
Android Things is the optimized
version of Android 4 devices.
It is a secure OS
from the ground up.
It is a full OS.
We, as the Google, will provide
secure patches, OS updates,
like we would do on your phone.
If you have an Android phone,
you get all those updates.
You don't have to
really think about it
versus if you have a
Linux server, for example,
in the cloud.
And when updates
are available, you
have to go patch and update and
maintain and test all of that.
We do all that for you
with Android Things.
You do not have to manage
those environments on your own.
Google will provide you the
firmware update, the OS update,
the security patches,
and the infrastructure
to deploy those
patches to the devices
through the same back end
that actually deploys updates
to your Android phones.
It's a very
battle-tested back end.
Those update processes have
been used millions, hundreds
of millions of times already.
It's a very secure way to send
those updates, very secure way
to have an OS that you
don't have to worry about.
Other benefits-- you can use
Android developers to build
apps on Android Things.
It's the same IDE, same
language, same everything.
It's really the same
as an Android device.
Very easy to deploy
an application.
You can run TensorFlow models.
on Android things, so run
machine learning, intelligence,
on the edge.
And you also have the Cloud IoT
connectivity as part of the OS.
So you can communicate with
Cloud IoT Core and the Cloud
IoT platform very easily
by using Android Things.
So it's a good option.
The only downside
of Android Things
is you have to use certified
SOMs, so system and modules,
certified hardware, that we
have tested and validated
to work with Android Things.
So we have a relationship with
Qualcomm, with NXP, with Arm.
I believe some others.
Can't remember
exactly the full list.
But we have a bunch of modules
like that that you can use.
And those are the only
approved hardware-- or some--
that can be used
by Android Things.
So that's the only downside.
So if it's possible for
you to choose one of those,
Android Things is
a great option.
Otherwise, you'd have to
revert to something else.
And I believe that's about it.
If you want to know
more about Cloud IoT,
you can go on that simple
URL, cloud.google.com/iot.
You'll find sample code.
You'll find example
documentation,
a little bit of an overview
of the infrastructure.
I invite you to come to Next.
It's in a couple of weeks.
That's something you
really want to see.
There's going to be a lot
of IoT talks over there.
And that's about it.
So stay tuned for the life Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Hey, welcome back for the
Q&A around security and IoT.
So we have a few questions
from the audience
here, so let's look at that.
I like the use of a
hardware root of trust,
but many of our
customers don't have
that in their current design.
What can they do?
That's a good question,
because I was emphasizing
the use of hardware.
And it's true.
There's a lot of
hardware out there
that don't have a root of trust.
So how do we handle that?
Because at first, you don't
have to use the root of trust.
You can still
connect to IoT Core
and benefit from the
JWT authentication,
from the independence
on the TLS stack
and all the security
of the back end.
So let's put it that way.
You can still use Cloud IoT
Core without the root of trust.
That's totally fine.
If you don't have one but you
want to add one to your design,
there's several ways to do that.
Those little cryptos I showed
you, the Microchip one,
for example, use
I2C as a protocol
to communicate with the rest
of the board, the PCB it's on.
I2C is very common
on most devices,
and you'll find a lot
of retrofit hardware
that you can add to an
I2C bus on the hardware,
either through a hat
that you plug in.
There's a nice hat that
exists for pies, for example.
As an example, put a hat.
It has the crypto on it.
You can use that
to retrofit design.
And the cool thing about
I2C is you can do it hot,
so you don't have to
shut down the device.
That's pretty cool.
You can just add that
crypto to existing devices.
Other customers
I've seen doing is
they use communication chips.
So for example, you have a
device that's not connected,
like in manufacturing, a PLC
on a manufacturing line that is
not connected to the internet.
They'll add a
communication module.
And inside the
communication module,
like a Wi-Fi or ethernet, you'll
have a crypto already in there
that you can start using.
And actually, the
encryption is all
dealt by the communication
devices itself, not the MCU
or the CPU.
So that's a great
way to also retrofit
without touching
the existing design.
Just add the communication
chip, Wi-Fi, ethernet, whatever,
serial, and then
add the crypto that
has the crypto embedded in it.
So there are ways to do that.
It's mostly a retrofit
world, but it's
easy to retrofit because
of the I2C communication.
That's very standard.
Another question.
It still seems like the best way
to secure devices is changing.
Changing devices, I assume.
Should we wait until--
is there any reason
for the customers
to hold off any longer?
So I think the question
here is more around,
we need to change
everything to be secure.
But I don't think that's OK.
So I think you
shouldn't hold off.
I think if you're
doing a design today,
if you put a hardware
root of trust
on it, if you put
a little crypto,
you're basically future proof.
You'll be able to update
that hardware root of trust
if you need.
You'll be able to rely on
that hardware root of trust
to do a lot of
security improvement,
key rotation, new
generation of certificates,
validation of boot firmware,
images, and all of that.
So there's no reason to wait.
I think, overall, the
security is there.
It's a matter of
implementing it.
And we've seen that it
could be complicated,
but with a solution
with IoT Core,
with hardware root of trust and
the partnership with Microchip,
for example, those
things are very much
solved and various solutions
for security today.
And you shouldn't wait.
You can be secure
pretty easily today
with the solutions
we have out there.
So there's no reason to wait.
In terms of price,
you said sub $1.
This is still very
expensive for small devices.
Are there ways to
lower these costs?
So yes, it's subdollar.
And it depends on the
volume, obviously.
But it's not over a dollar.
Depends on volume.
So I would say if you're looking
at low-cost devices, people
that have bombs that are
maybe $20, $30 or even less,
that means you're already
looking, oftentimes,
at fairly high volumes.
Because otherwise, you
can't get those bombs down.
And that means that you're going
to get volume discounts, as
well, on those chips.
So you'll be way
lower than a dollar.
So that's one thing to know.
If you have volume,
subdollar is a guidance.
But you'll get volume
discounts on that.
The other thing is you have
to think about the costs
holistically.
It's not just the
cost of the bomb.
It's what it saves you
in manufacturing costs,
in maintenance, in reputation
cost or dollar amount lost
through a hack
that could happen,
and the ease of
maintaining that over time.
There's a ton of costs
maintaining things over time,
maintaining things
secure over time,
that this little crypto
subdollar will solve for you.
And in my opinion, it is
well worth it to spend that.
The bomb will be a little
higher for your devices.
But it's so much cheaper
overall, holistically,
than you can really
see or get without it.
Are there other questions
than this coming up?
OK.
So I mean, well, stay
tuned for the next session.
We have a [INAUDIBLE] chat,
efficiently migrating data
into the Google
Cloud Platform, which
will be pretty interesting.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]